quand j'ai commencé ma main est encore
bondi de nice est très jolie course
bonjour à vous content de vous retrouver
de copenhague au danemark yamna
d'épicerie
[Musique]
bonjour ici denis gagné et au menu cette
semaine du homard des tétines de souris
as tu eu le goût d'y goûter oui non bien
sûr ah ouais j'avais une sensation de
douleur laissez vous tenter
[Musique]
le reportage qui suit contient des cinq
qui pourraient vous surprendre
baba pape et
toi tu es mon ami
[Musique]
mais d'autres étaient encore
sur dur
[Musique]
sa classe et petit état séparé strict
c'est un grenelle
tout une bouchée
[Musique]
c'est encore la confusion dans
l'affichage de la provenance des fruits
et légumes les différentes initiatives
pour nous faire adopter les légumes que
l'on dimanche où un parfait connaissent
beaucoup de succès on essaie de
comprendre pourquoi encore aujourd'hui
on y vend des fruits et légumes à la
chopine sont nettement trop salée les
sel le sel c'est seul hic il y a quinze
ans le premier reportage de lippi ci
souligne un conte consommer trop de
sodium dans notre alimentation
malheureusement il est encore vingt ans
plus tard toujours d'actualité
[Musique]
cette semaine on retour dans l'enfance
ans quand j'étais petit je connaissais
pas ce soit des sushis les merguez le
riz basmati le couscous pour choisir
livré avec ça une caisse de qui coule ou
du goûter qui tient pas vraiment merci
des révélateurs de souvenirs d'enfance
ça c'en est un côté des poêlons en acier
inoxydable
nous sommes que je passe mon frère l'a
remplacé ma peau notre désir est
vraiment celle que je préférais je
trouve que pour la viande rouge c'est
dur à battre une enquête sur le boeuf
angus les amateurs de viandes rouges
sont gâtés à beaucoup de gens qui
cherchent des alternatives aux viandes
traditionnels je me demande encore
comment ça se prépare de l'utérus de
porc c'est dommage parce que c'est
délicieux et c'est très facile à paris
est ce que c'est une façon pour
l'industrie d'attirer notre attention
alors que les ventes d'un bug stagne ou
est ce tout simplement une viande de
plus grande qualité
regardons d'abord quel est le véritable
taux de matières grasses de votre
peuvent fâcher lacombe à savoir mais une
portion c'est quoi au juste dans le cas
de la viande c'est 85 g c'est
l'équivalent la dimension de la paume de
la main ou encore d'un jeu de cartes
pour vous messieurs une rondelle de
hockey rassurez vous ça goûte pas ce que
ça sent après cuisson ou encore séché
beaucoup de confusion spermatique des
beurs de soya qui se prennent pour du
beurre d'arachide saviez-vous
bien il ya de poulet dans un bateau
coule et cela s'il vous plaît encore est
ce qu'une poule donne un meilleur qu'une
autre mais nous on est curieux mythe ou
réalité on savoir confondre les
sceptiques et sans vous casser les
nenets mais ça c'est à vous de juger
[Musique]
pour être à 100 t on dit souvent qu'il
faut faire comme dans le temps
d'entendre nos grands parents c'est à
dire manger peu de produits transformés
manger plus de fruits et légumes et
bouger beaucoup plus on commande une
pizza
en termes de grands de sodium et de
calories le trio pizza c'est
l'équivalent du trio a de toute évidence
est en cuisine en soi même des aliments
sains comprend réel virage santé le
mélange sucré et légumineuses 7 pas
heureux non sap explosifs comme idée
amusez-vous à cuisiner
[Musique]
c'est un produit bien intéressant parce
qu'il est à usages multiples
oui à l'eau estime que
la vente
classement c'est le moment de vous
parler des bons d'achat faire cette
semaine c'est un fromage fermier au lait
cru de brebis c'est donc le lait de ces
demoiselles derrière moi fin des pommes
de terre à moins 3 semaines se
transforme en d'étranges créatures son
goût est doux et délicat et sa chair est
ferme et malgré ce qu'on pense c'est un
fruit peu sucré on l'appelle aussi
chapeau de prêtres de par sa forme
originelle
acheter en vrac une bonne idée mais
est-ce risqué du point de vue salubrité
je me pose toujours la même question
quand j'arrivais ce que c'est propre les
restes de l'un font parfois le bonheur
de l'autre mais dans ce cas ci ils font
le bonheur de tous c'est facile de
mettre un sourire dans un visage ça
prend beaucoup de vin sans dire que ça
ne fonctionne pas nous n'avons trouvé
aucune évidence scientifique à l'effet
que ce soit vraiment comme trois fois
par jour on jongle à se demander ce
qu'on va manger on devra intégrer des
insectes à notre alimentation
êtes vous prêts est ce que ces mangeurs
sur papier c'était un peu étrange mais
s'accroche et crown succulentes pour eux
aussi beau plat sans gras sans celle ci
n'en tient qu'à vous de les utiliser
pour exprimer votre créativité culinaire
et pas besoin d'en mettre beaucoup pour
que ça goûte il y a trois ans la
consommation de cannabis devenait légal
au canada l'épicerie tous ceux qui
nagent se fume et au ne connaît pas les
effets à long terme sur la santé du
grand marché de québec
[Musique]
oui
et bien voilà c'est déjà tout pour sa
semaine merci beaucoup d'avoir été des
nôtres merci de nous accueillir
suivez-vous merci de nous être toujours
aussi fidèle on se sent privilégié
j'espère que vous avez apprécié notre
incursion sur cette île magnifique sur
ce passé une excellente semaine amusez
vous bien dans les pc holisme rabotage
et 20 ans bravo à toi aussi
[Musique]
merci démunis
et